[Music]
hi everyone I'm here with Mary Kish
former GameSpot producer or if you watch
our series on gamespot Resident Evil
you know she sucks at Resident Evil and
we're here playing Resident will to
remake which we've been excited for yeah
today announced it on Sony stage it
looks like our party's been canceled cut
this is very weird it's surreal hello is
anybody here my first day
come in it's not a safe box behind you
yes yes Wow the sound effects are just
better
okay that sounds it'll probably use that
shortly imagine you know I don't know
the buttons for this so it's a bit I
didn't get a knife
that's from Rosina 70 okay so I need a
nice to get in here just tape I forget
where I'm going the liquor hallway near
the front door
let's go you know there's a button on
the computer in the old game now I will
sketch that I know I can't concentrate
what a fox there has to be someone here
he looks so good
not good
Marvin Branagh
soon reinforcements
these totally
you okay
all right so we're going here
[Music]
is it broken
[Music]
I'm gonna crawl
plant
Israeli plan
and I earn
okay a fuse we need a fuse
Oh gross one of my hands
whaaa it's hard enough the same guy they
all
I did this will actually isn't big
enough maybe to help
my god
ah that guy's butt is bleeding there's
something wrong that guys play hey your
butts on your butts bloody butt
Jesus
I'll get you out
right
ah
[Applause]
this is a far darker tale than last time
you know he did you check his pulse
statue lady's statue with the Vaz lion
statue with the what
returns in the mail
that scared the [ __ ] out of me
let's go there's no more door loading
screens it's a that breather during I'd
like fluting how do I go oh no this is
what I wanted [ __ ]
where am I going
bhaktas places so confusing
yeah over here
oh no not whoops Jesus [ __ ] they're
everywhere [ __ ] I don't have to pull it
you have 26
sure dick nice
where
Oh
Oh
no way is this Marvin crush it it looks
like your parties and castles
[Laughter]
thanks say it
Marvin brother Leon Kennedy there was
another office right I could
yeah
sure you did what you could
does anyone else start this
looks really again honestly all you need
to know is that this place will eat you
in body you want careful you know I'm
supposed to start last week when I got a
call a stay away or should I come here
sooner
hey lieutenant I'm ready
we'll be able to find a way out of this
station but officer you met her
you've got this super pastoral light of
the trick
you look tired Marvin and dying
nice
we all know how good you are with those
yeah
are you know Coppola back team oh yeah
this is not how I imagined my first day
this pot likker hallway it might be a
liqueur on the ceiling oh no they're not
God why is everything like this
Oh
he's on alive
it was one bullet No
this is no liquor hallway right
I have no fear whoa it's a licker claw
do it
like you know what's happening he's
gonna crawl across the window isn't he
crap
noise
see that
sneaky sneaky
yeah dad he's dead
that noise
I don't know where I am
Oh God all right Mary you and I played
through rez equal to like a year or two
ago what you think is a remake so far
its way scarier when you're playing over
the shoulder like that I mean the first
thing that I felt was just like way more
immersions
darker that dude got his bottom half
chewed off I felt like the controls were
tight I enjoy getting headshots when I
could and it was really often getting
that a kill of a knife at all days it's
definitely possible and functional it's
like a little more fluid resident for if
you could aim while moving
it's like revelations that you played 1
& 2 but yeah overall much darker tone
but there's you can choose to use
typewriters to save otherwise there's a
more modern like autosave kind of system
as well if you maybe jump in with
Resident 7 it really is like crispy
before I'm really glad you said that
because the first time I was able to
play it over the shoulder I felt like
the game was just immediately scarier
just it just is that way because you
feel so much closer to the combat so to
have re to with this over the shoulder
is also there's stuff can come up behind
you and you don't just see it yeah stuff
came up behind us while we were actually
playing which was rude not only is the
writing totally different but the voice
acting is actually way better I actually
felt like his character
really believable and really well done
so I mean for for this it feels like a
different game I still feel like I'm
playing are you too but it's just like
they redid it not just like a I don't
know it's not screen for screaming redo
of the of the original and there's lots
of surprises everywhere yeah it's not
just a remake in terms of the
perspective that you're seeing it from
but also sounds like maybe Claire would
have her own campaign I'm sorry she had
her own campaign in too but it's
actually like not just a similar one the
a/b scenario it's like its own thing
that'll be cool they can said that you
can you will be playing as her but they
didn't really say what and we only got
like this very small taste of it but I
mean from what I saw I mean you're
getting your beloved Artie to but with
like this style and all the hard love
and soul of re seven language so crazy
so you're basically just getting the
best of both worlds I'm looking forward
to playing this
[Music]